buddy cop comedy is brought to you by
Max Payne and Ricky Bobby the other guys
all right so let's be perfectly honest
at this point in existence we all know
that buddy cop comedy czar not usually
like Lethal Weapon a rush hour they're
actually more like the other guys and
that's not to say the other guys didn't
have its laughs at least chuckles but
it's just not we're sitting through two
hours I mean the trailer for the other
guys looked hilarious it made it look
like it was gonna be Hollywood's
official apology for cop-out if this is
an apology it's like a Mel Gibson
apology this is [ __ ] so the other
guy's a standard basic buddy cop comedy
formula Will Ferrell and Marky Mark
they're a couple of nobodies at the
precinct but Marky Mark he wants his big
shot at being a badass oh dragged his
partner Will Ferrell along with him then
they follow these leads to a big
conspiracy nobody believes them and then
you know the whole give me a badge it's
both here off the case
formula ensues can you tell I had some
problems with this movie first of all
I'm thinking about it and I noticed
there is not one likable character in
this movie every one of the characters
in this movie are either douchebags
[ __ ] morons idiots or [ __ ]
so actually that's not true Michael
Keaton is the captain he was cool and he
was the funniest one in this movie this
movie feels like the premise would have
been okay if it was like this
reoccurring skit on SNL you know in
5-minute increments it's like when my
brother rented the mr. bill collection
then we watched the whole thing with
five minute increments would have been
funny two hours straight no now we
cannot deny that Will Ferrel plays the
oblivious idiot character really really
well I mean I'll give him that I don't
think the guy breaks character like ever
but there are just other movies out
there in which Will Ferrell plays the
oblivious idiot character and it's a
better movie so just go watch that but
Mark Wahlberg's character could've been
played by anybody could have been played
by Donnie Wahlberg and it wouldn't made
a difference Mark Wahlberg what's
happening to you this movie just did not
know what it wanted to be I mean is it
like a spoof buddy cop comedy is it like
a more realistic buddy cop comedy like
Lethal Weapon it doesn't know so it
stays in the middle and you're confused
so when it tries to be like a more
realistic comedy and something
unrealistic happens you just go it is
[ __ ] that wouldn't happen rather
than go that is [ __ ] but it's funny
and it's okay because it's comedy like
Will Ferrell being married to Eva Mendes
that is [ __ ] but honestly I can kind
of see why this movie got greenlit
because the funny moments in this movie
are the kind of funny moments that they
look like they're going to be really
funny when they're on paper but then
when you actually see it yeah I mean
Dinner for Schmucks had its problems but
Dinner for Schmucks was funnier than the
other guys
say that so if you really feel like you
just have to go out and watch a comedy
this weekend and you have bled your
Netflix comedy section dry si Dinner for
Schmucks but if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]